hi and thanks for the warm welcome my
name is Dan birkenstock I was a PhD
student here in arrow not extent
astronautics from two thousand four to
two thousand nine ish got a little
confusing at the end there yeah not
quite sure what's happening um just for
quick intro so everyone knows we've got
Ching you who another co-founder who was
in MS&E we've got John fennec who was in
the business school and we've got Julian
man before we get started maybe just a
little bit of sort of know your audience
so how many people here today are
engineers good all right good good how
many people in the business school
alright that's presenter yeah represent
yeah he go John not bad you not bad um
how many people here today because they
want to start a company mmm that's good
skybox doesn't work we got a lot of
backup options to go up there you'll
find here and finally before the
announcement went out for this etl
lecture how many people had ever heard
of skybox imaging that's what I expected
not very many so we're excited to be
here today to tell you a little bit more
about our company in large part because
people don't really know us yet we've
been at this thing for a little while
but we're still in kind of a soft
stealth mode as we get up into the
launch of our first products and
satellites later this year so to tell
you a little bit more and kind of get
everybody up to speed before we get into
the fun stuff we at skybox imaging have
been around for about four years we
incorporated in 2009 we raised 91
million dollars there's kind of a lot of
money it feels like for a company that
most people haven't heard of we've got
six months to the launch of our first
satellite sky SAT one we've got a pretty
awesome team we started off by hiring
all of our best friends from Stanford
and we've just kind of kept going from
there and at this point we've got people
that have worked on a really a very
interesting variety of space missions
and big
data companies here in Silicon Valley
and our vision at skybox is we'll talk
about a lot more today is to
dramatically increase the overall size
of what we like to call the overhead
monitoring market so how are we going to
do that well at skybox we build
satellites that are about the size of a
small refrigerator and are built using
commercial off-the-shelf electronics
open source software and really all the
other tricks of the trade that have made
Silicon Valley scalable commoditized
hardware agile development all these
types of things now in order to really
create that new market of tomorrow we
want to be able to monitor tens or even
hundreds of thousands of locations on
earth on a daily basis the only way to
do that is to put up lots of satellites
the only way to put up lots of
satellites is to put up very low-cost
satellites we've spent the last four
years designing very low-cost satellites
that can still provide images that are
attractive to the market of today as we
create the market of tomorrow and these
images look like this so you can see an
airplane you can see a shipping
container you can see a car you can see
railroad cars you can see really objects
of this scale that move around the
surface of our earth on a daily basis
and heavily inform economic activity and
then also the security of nations around
our planet you can't see a license plate
you can't see a person and you really
can't even tell oh it's John's car
versus Julian's car versus Ching news
car I don't know if John actually has a
car so that probably makes it easier in
addition by taking advantage of sort of
the Silicon Valley approach to building
satellites we got a pretty interesting
side benefit that our satellites don't
just produce imagery they produce video
as well and so will be marketing the the
world's first high-resolution video from
space that we hope people will help
people gain a much better insight and a
daily basis into how things are
happening across our across our world
what's exciting to us though is not just
the imagery it's not just the video
being able to sort of move beyond what
you might see in Google Maps or Bing
Maps today into being able to provide
the data the answer to the question not
just the picture of the parking lot but
an answer for how many cars are within
it and how does that compare to what
happened last week last month last year
and how do we roll that up onto a global
scale so that for the first time we
really can put an information source in
the hands of consumers businesses and
governments around the world that can
dramatically increase their ability to
make efficient profitable and safe
decisions as they go about their daily
lives so that's that's the elevator
pitch for those of you who are taking
273 I know you're all practicing
elevator pitches when we took 273 they
actually made us get an elevator with
someone on the first floor of Turman and
give them the elevator pitch by the time
we got to the fourth floor so now that
we've had for years to hone it and we've
been able to spend a lot of time
perfecting that but what I think is
really interesting for us is all the
tough lessons that we've learned as we
got outside the building and decided
that we were actually going to build a
company called skybox imaging which
today is over 80 people has invested
tens of millions of dollars has
developed a significant amount of
technology and quite frankly still
hasn't proven itself still has a very
long way to go in the cycle of really
being able to make it happen so we'll
start off with kind of the actual
backstory on Sky box which isn't on our
website and doesn't go in the slides in
2007 I was in my three or four ish year
of my PhD when Google actually announced
something called the google lunar xprize
so this was a 20 million dollar prize
for a commercial team that could land a
rover on the surface of the moon she
could drive around take pictures and
send back the data now having spent a
lot of time and what we called The Hurt
Locker any arrow Astro students here all
right we got a couple so this was
actually the old hurt locker I'm kind of
dating myself now but we had a bunch of
people that really
we're in our friend circle and had
either worked on cube sets which are
breadbox sized satellites that use
commercial electronics an approach was
that was invented here at Stanford about
a decade ago to dramatically reduce the
price point of doing business in space
we also had people that were good at
software they were good at mechanical
design that we're good at optics that
were good at ironically program
management in some cases and in looking
around it seemed like this might be
something we could do at Stanford stay
over 21 the DARPA Grand Challenge a
couple years before and this seemed like
sort of a moonshot you know of a
follow-on program we had 40 students
that were all gung ho and making this
happen we were thinking about initial
high level designs you know and we being
able to take this approach that had been
sort of developed and fleshed out over
the last decade to build cube SATs and
applying that same design approach to a
moon mission unfortunately as I'm sure
many of you remember the winter of
2007-2008 wasn't really the best time to
try and get new initiative started they
were going to cost tens of millions of
dollars the complete economy collapsed
out from under us and you know some of
the soft offers that we had had for for
potential financing for this thing
dissipated overnight so I think we've
learned one of the most important
lessons at that point that we've carried
with us over the last four years now and
that's really sort of a rugged
determination even after the universe
told us know by letting you know
creating the the worst financial crisis
in nearly a hundred years and we set
ourselves look we're at Stanford where
all these amazing companies are founded
sand hill road where the venture
capitalists are is you know mile and a
half away we have this really unique
group of people that have this idea of
how do we take sort of the the things
that have made commercial success in
Silicon Valley and made it scalable and
cost effective and inject that into
aerospace for the first time and so we
just started pulling on that thread we
started out as a technology looking for
a market which I'm sure is a common
theme and a number of these lectures and
we had a
paper at a conference we came back we
got one introduction to one venture
capitalist we walked into his office
with four awful slides and a sort of
prototype of what we thought a satellite
could eventually look like and he said
you know this is pretty cool but you
guys have no idea what you're talking
about there's this class MS&E 273 go
take it and that was some of the best
advice we ever got so we came back to
Stanford for that school year we took
msn a 273 we had the opportunity to get
outside the building to really to make
use of the fact that we were still
Stanford students it's amazing the
response you get from people when you
cold call a you know a value-added
reseller of satellite imagery in
Anchorage Alaska and tell them oh hi my
name is Dan I'm a Stanford student we're
working on a project can I get ten
minutes of your time right and so we
started out it's kind of pushing pushing
pushing on trying to understand the
market up today developing out you know
the business plan putting together a
pitch and then we never really talked
about it but somehow we all just knew
deep down that we were going to go out
and incorporate and we're going to try
and make this thing reality and so after
the class finished january i think 15th
no we worked with the attorney we had
met in the class to put in place the
documentation to actually have a
registered company and at that point you
know go out you buy the godaddy domain
you get your email address set up you
put that signature line in there and you
set yourself an email and it's like the
coolest thing ever like i just got an
email from myself at my own company
right and it felt like a company at the
time which is funny because it wasn't a
company at all it was just four of us
hanging out in John's living room with
his cats that scratched everything
including jinyu's face and Julian's arms
and all of our macbook pros right and so
so from there you know it felt like a
company we had our Monday morning
meetings we still have monday morning
meetings today and more people at him
but you know we set out our action items
we went after trying to do them and
trying to improve our story and we
started looking around for introductions
to people that might be interested in
financing something as different as an
enterprise that involved satellites
right and so as I'm sure many of you
have already seen and know Stanford has
an amazing set of resources to help get
you out there and to actually talk to
people that can make these things
reality and so now we spent four six and
a half months we spent at least two days
a week doing three pitches a day to over
50 different venture capital firms we I
had more lattes at coupa cafe then I
will ever be able to detox out of my
system for the rest of my life and and
you know we get to the third pitch of
the day and we'd all be so slap happy
that we just be like throwing a football
back and forth we'd all deliver each
other's lines right and we just honed it
and worked it and pushed it and called
more customers and met more people and
ask for more introductions and
eventually we got introduced to Vinod
Khosla and we went and gave a pitch at
khosla ventures which after you know a
lot of digging and fact-checking turned
into a three-million-dollar Series A
which allowed us to move out of John's
living room into what we thought was an
amazing 2,100 square foot office that
had a nice little machine shop in the
back with carpet on the ground in a
conference room but which felt like a
real company and from there we learned
we began learning about not just how you
sell the company but how you build the
company and one of the most telling
points on that was as we walked in for
our first board of directors meeting
about three days after he closed the
series a with that I'm going to turn it
over to mr. Mann here thanks Dan so I'm
Julian as was already said and I was
getting my co term in aeronautics and
astronautics here when I met Dan and
John and I was in particular working in
the space systems development lab which
has been building these cube SATs
mentioned and we were really at the
stage of them where we were starting to
apply them to more and more
sophisticated science missions and when
I wasn't thinking about that I was
trying to figure out how to control the
satellites with my iPhone and so I also
spent about a year working at NASA on
the manned space program and it was
really in that experience that I
realized oh my god this technology that
we have in the lab has the ability to
disrupt this massive massive industry
but we have to figure out a way of
getting it away from the academic
research grant world and into the you
know serious investment world that will
allow us to accelerate the development
and so for me that was when after a
little false start chasing government
research small business kind of
opportunities reconnected with Dan and
John and skybox became a reality but
back to the first board meeting so there
we are sitting in our in the closet of
an office that we have at the time and I
was the the CTO at the time and being
the good aerospace engineer that I was I
knew that it was my job to convince that
we heard to convey that we had a
credible plan for going from concept to
satellite on orbit and that obviously
means having a schedule and more
importantly especially if you're an
aerospace engineer it means having a
Gantt chart so I was sitting there in
Excel making a Gantt chart I think I had
really great line titles like 1.1 1.2
2.2 I think there was a date occur a
time line across the bottom of the chart
but I'm not confident of that they were
definitely knows 8 you will yes and dry
annual that no dates within the chart
maybe some like variable with colored
lines and we get into the board meeting
and I put up this chart and I start
explaining it and I may have gotten two
or three sentences in before my first
instruction which was go buy a copy of
microsoft project and learn how to use
it and go by this very specific book on
budget and schedule management and read
it cover to cover and why don't you come
back next month and we'll try this again
so the lesson of the board reading is
whatever you're doing you're doing it
wrong figure it out improve keep going
we walked out of the board meeting
you know ultimately we was probably
probably did better than then we could
have and realize now we have to go hire
some people we're trying to build a
satellite we're going to need at least
like 10 or 15 engineers to make this
whole thing work and they're going to
need to be from a number of different
engineering disciplines and it turns out
through the process of raising the
series a investors would often ask us
you know can you give us some examples
of the types of people that you're going
to go higher so we would go to our
friends in grad school and say hey can
you lend us your resume we just need an
example of the type of person you know
just so we can get across the finish
line we're not trying to convince you to
like leave your PhD or the cushy
corporate job you just got but then
suddenly you're sitting there with this
long list of positions that you need to
fill and of course we just immediately
turned around and started turning up the
heat on them to actually jump ship and
come join the team and apparently we
must have done something right because
Dan already mentioned about the first
ten people we hired we're all our
friends from school so turns out hiring
your friends when you need to hire fast
sometimes actually works you know
another thing that that I think often
about in those early days as I'm sure
many people in this room have heard
heard the term product market fit and
iterating your technology to market and
I couldn't agree more with with the
necessity to do that I add one small
piece to that maxim which is rapidly
iterate your technology to market but
don't kill your team in the process and
so right as we finished up the series a
financing we had this reference point
design for the satellite really was in a
back-of-the-envelope conceptual design
saying this might be feasible and at the
time the satellite was going to produce
two two and a half meter resolution not
quite the quality that dan showed up on
the the pictures of the slides a few
minutes ago but reasonably good but we
got out there and we started really
talking to people we found is we
probably need something a little better
we probably need to get close closer
down to one meter resolution and so we
began this four or five month process
where
every two or three days dan would walk
in the office and say all right like we
need to figure out how to get just like
five percent more performance out of the
system and we were just churning out new
designs new designs new designs running
you know this kind of analysis that kind
of analysis and was preceded and
satellite kept growing and growing and
growing and one day Dan walks in and he
had the look on his face that I knew men
we need five percent more out of the
system so I grabbed him took him into
the conference room which was like in
the middle of the windowless office and
said then I understand what you're doing
I can take it but Mike our vp of
satellite systems is going to have a
heart attack if you ask for five percent
more from the system one more time and
I'm pretty sure that was the last time
the system grab so just don't kill the
team in the process of trying a global
optimization by watching people's
forehead veins the next thing I like to
talk about is uh is the importance of
flirting and I don't mean in the
romantic sense you know the technology
at skybox is really based upon the
convergence of sort of these two
technology pillars these satellite
miniaturization and the now exceedingly
buzzword big data that's been swirling
around the valley for the last few years
but we knew as we were looking at this
that as we launch more and more
satellites the volume of data that we
were going to have to be storing and
processing and making accessible to our
users was going to be increasing
incredibly rapidly now on the on the
same type of growth curve as you know
Facebook's photo stores and we knew that
doing that was going to require a lot of
you know engineering and ingenuity if we
were going to do it in any way
differently from the traditional guys
which spent hundreds of millions of
dollars on legacy infrastructure to do
this and our network was pretty pretty
heavily skewed towards the aerospace
side so we knew we had to find some
other people and turned out that a Dan's
wife's friend from works husband was you
know a big data software guy am and so
we started talking to him very early on
you know come by the office for a beer
let's help us figure out
maybe like what do we need to do to
think about storing this how do we think
about like back hauling all this data
from places like Norway and Fairbanks
Alaska and you know that preceded for a
year and the meetings went from you know
once every two months to once every
three weeks and suddenly you know a year
later it's like all right you need to
join our team to actually lead up this
effort and that didn't just happen once
that happened all the time and it didn't
just happen with hiring it happened with
with VCS that first the first VC that
Dan mentioned that we pitched before we
took 273 didn't didn't participate in
the series a but became our lead
investor in the series b so you really
never know what relationships you're
going to build early that are going to
bear fruit and my biggest lesson learned
from that is think about what skills and
assistance and partnerships and support
you're going to need not just today but
tomorrow and start investing in those
relationships early because when you do
they will pay huge huge dividends and my
my sort of parting thought here is is on
the fact that all it really takes is a
simple idea and with skybox it's really
easy to sort of get stuck thinking about
the fact that we're doing things like
building satellites and buying rockets
and doing all the stuff around the world
but ultimately the core idea behind
skybox was really really simple we were
building satellites that looked and felt
like pcs in a satellite world where
everybody else was building mainframes
and as we started going out and telling
people that story we realized that yeah
there's a big opportunity when you
dramatically reduce the cost of
something and an increase its
accessibility this is a pattern that
breeds interesting results and so we
just kept pulling on that threat I think
Dan already used that that term once and
so all it takes is a simple idea and if
you if you chase that simple idea and
you dream big and anytime anybody tells
you that your idea is stupid and you
shouldn't do it you completely ignore
them because you know that what you're
doing is absolutely essential and going
to change the world then you have a real
possibility of doing it keep pursuing it
hey guys i'm john and i'm going to
provide some corollaries to what julian
has mentioned but first a bit of a
backstory my part of the skybox story
starts with a dream and you guys might
guess what that dream is but actually I
dream as a kid all I ever wanted to be
was a fighter pilot you know I watched
Top Gun and Iron Eagle over and over and
over again that's all I wanted to do but
as I went to the Air Force Academy I
studied my rear end off and you know got
to the point where I was ready to do it
I'm all set I'm gonna go be a fighter
pilot life is going to be good there's
one problem is that my eyesight was
pretty poor so I had laser eye surgery
of course that's what you do and that
surgery failed and the three subsequent
surgeries trying to fix the damage that
was caused that first surgery made it so
I could drive but never get in a cockpit
so here I was air force officer that
couldn't fly what was I to do and so
that's how I got into the satellite
business I was going to have to fly a
desk I mahogany desk it might as well be
doing satellite stuff and so I got to
the point where I learned how to build
and fly really large massive satellites
for the government in fact my last job
in the Air Force was I was the guy who
went to Capitol Hill and I looked
senators and congressmen in the eyes and
said we got to keep building more big
massive satellites those mainframe ones
that Julian referenced but to be honest
my heart wasn't really in it it wasn't
really creative or innovative it was
just a lot more of the same so I decided
I need a little bit of a breather from
the military-industrial complex so i
wrote my business school applications
essays to the GSB here and they were
just littered with references about how
I wanted to start a small satellite
company it sounded really good at red
awesome but to be honest my heart wasn't
really in it I didn't I just thought
that was a pipe dream I was all set to
go off and go chase mobile apps or
whatever else was out here in Silicon
Valley I thought I was going to leave
the satellite world behind and it was
only after a number of beers and a
number of doodles on a cocktail napkin
with Julian and Dan and see why we're
I got back into it and said you know
what there's a way to do this
differently and and so that's that's
what got me here as part of this team
and what I'd like to relay is is to
lessons as we've got going that add some
sort of pragmatic reality 22 what we're
trying to do you know Julian says all it
takes is a big idea I would argue that
that big audacious really hairy goal is
necessary but for getting a business
going it's it's not sufficient you have
to find that near-term path to revenue
to make the company tick to make
investors happy to make it all work and
there's a few stories that we learned
that lesson the hard way right after we
incorporated got our email addresses is
Dan described the first thing we did we
put on our ties and we flew right to
Wall Street and we went open the door to
a hedge fund and said guess what we're
doing we're going to do near real-time
overhead monitoring from above
everywhere it's going to be awesome and
then we slid the paper across their
Destin's just said it was just sign here
we're good to go we're going to we're
going to be partners right and as you
might surmise there was no deal to be
had those guys looked at us and said
yeah it's cute and all but come back to
us when you're real come back to us when
you have real data well it turns out
that's a real challenge we're going to
get real data from a satellite that was
still years away from being reality so
we looked at ourselves and looked each
other and said well what do we do how do
we how do we provide interim proof
points in a business where the real
milestone is putting things in space at
large cost you know it turns out skybox
is a lot more like a medical device
company or a sound like conductor chip
fab and that you put a gazillion dollars
in before you get one dollar out and
before you have that alpha product I
mean we're four years in we still don't
have a product and we're working towards
it so we put our heads together and came
up with well okay we're engineers so we
busted out our laptops and started to
write you know in MATLAB made ourselves
some simulated imagery held that up to
customers mad didn't do much
so then we said okay we'll buy out all
the satellite imagery that we can find
today and and hold that up to customers
and so it will just imagine close your
eyes that instead of six months old this
is one hour old instead of a still
picture it's video and instead of being
two grand it's going to be 20 bucks it
got a little bit of the juices flowing
and the customers but still wasn't
enough so finally we said screw it and
we went and bought a Learjet and drilled
a hole in the bottom and put a camera to
be able to fully replicate what we're
going to see from space well that helped
actually quite a bit it was pretty fun
in the process and so in doing so as we
finally got out and engaged with a bunch
of customers we realized that the people
that were going to work with us
initially weren't those hedge funds that
it was a bridge too far it turns out
that the folks that were most interested
had the most pain today that we could
help solve were international
organizations and governments that
didn't really want to go through the
hassle of putting up designing and
flying spacecraft themselves they just
wanted to borrow time on our first or
second spacecraft as it flew over their
territory and that was for us it was a
big shock we didn't we didn't appreciate
that fully until having gone through the
process of identifying and creating that
that proxy product that's the first
lesson that from a take away from us the
second one is that at a startup you
always were completely resource
constrained each one of us was trying to
do ten different jobs and getting
swamped in all of them and going out
there to do research about where the
customers were and the like was just a
real challenge with the satellite
imagery it's useful for you know
billions of different applications but
picking that subset that is most
lucrative most important for us
especially in the near term was was a
real challenge so we decided to focus on
those set of customers that were so
excited about what we were doing they
were willing to educate us about how
they were going to use it along the way
and it
start those first few customers those
early adopters we found be so valuable
we gave them a sweetheart deal you know
they're they've got their hooks into us
but it's okay because we're learning a
ton about what they need and it's really
informing our product development
process and the second thing that we've
done is from the get-go we've really
focused on building a platform whereby
people can access our data on a self
serve basis now I know platform in
Silicon Valley's a total buzz where
everyone says it but it turns out we
need to do it just to be able to expose
this all the third parties to be able to
figure out you know where is the killer
app in this type of data stream we
haven't figured it out yet but we think
by letting everyone play in this sandbox
that great things will come out of it
and so so with that I'd like to just
close my piece by saying that skybox the
challenge for us in making this big idea
reality is that we're trying to put a
lot of things together we're designing
and manufacturing spacecraft we're
launching and flying them we are putting
together a huge data infrastructure
we're doing crazy image processing
algorithms and a UI to be able to have
folks play with the data so it's really
skybox is more like five or six startups
in one so CY pass it over to you to talk
about how do we take those five startups
and turn it in something real that's
good thanks John well first off it's
great to be here I was listening to etl
lectures two years before you going to
apply to stanford which is 2005 so this
is just incredibly humbling to be back
here to share stories from Stanford to a
space startup and unlike the other three
I'm the only non rocket scientist of the
team I went to Berkeley undergrad
studied sistex and operational search
came directly here for my masters and
management science and engineering and I
met Dan John Julian and MC 273 and for
those of you who haven't taken it you
work in teams of four and they teach you
the basics of how to build a tech
startup and this was my last quarter at
Stanford and my worst calamity was to
waste my last few months at Stanford
just working on a normal
project of mediocre aspirations and so I
need going into the class that I didn't
want to work with the talented team but
i just wanted to work with the best and
so on the first day the class is
oversubscribed and the professor said
you have to raise your hand and say
something in order to stay in it and you
know many of the students started
raising their hands and saying you know
brainstorming ideas around iphone apps
and mobile social local ideas and the
three boys are sitting in the back and i
remembered an roses hand and said hi I'm
Dan I'm going to launch a consolation of
bread box size satellites to analyze the
earth in real time and he said it's so
emphatically I was just shocked and you
know John you know later says you know
I'm gonna you know create a company to
deliver pizzas via helicopter and the
class erupted in laughter and I thought
to myself well that's a really cheeky
comment but you have to be smart to meet
cheeky and so passion is a really
infectious thing is what you'll find and
I felt that all the way at the front of
the room where I was sitting and after
the first class adjourned I literally
ran up to them and I said hi I'm Qing
you I'd like to be part of your team and
twitch said who I think more I'm sure
you I'm gonna be infinity is the hair
and you know I've always been a really
soft spoken and kind of a reserved
person and to this day I'm just so
shocked that I was so bold and so
utterly shameless actually go up to
these guys and pretty much take no for
an answer and it wasn't till later that
I realized that actually all four of us
are really good at not taking no for an
answer and so you know after we left
Stanford you know we spent a couple
glorious months and John's living room
and when we got funded I mean we were
just so fired up to just do whatever it
took to take a graded business plan into
an actual business and so you know one
of the things that we really learned
when we moved into that a windowless
office that Dan was talking about with
termites falling on our customers we
learned how to be scrappy and reveled in
it most of the furniture that we got was
from the cheapest office liquidation
sale that we could find on craigslist we
found a free 8 foot conference table
that
spent the better half of an afternoon
trying to shuttle down a parking lot on
a skateboard our refrigerator came from
one of the dorms here on Stanford that
had rainbow colored mold that Dan and I
you know cleaned out we went to
conferences we would call them and say
we're Stanford grads and we can't afford
the Spade thousand dollar ticket can we
get it for 50 and most of the time we
get discounts like that and generally
speaking you'll just be surprised what
you get when you just just ask and you
know one of the things that was we
learned was when you have a company with
a really really big vision it really
helps to kind of surpass roadblocks just
to learn how to adopt a very healthy
disrespect for seemingly impossible
tasks and for us like nothing was too
big we needed regulatory licenses to
launch satellites and so we called our
attorneys we talk to our advisors
figured out how to do it and went out
and got it done we needed an optical
payload and so we were able to convince
one of the world's leading providers of
high-performance optics to design and
build the payload for the consolation we
needed market validation for financing
and we went out and cold called 350
customers you know and show traction
where we could and you know people
always ask us if the four of us had
drama or he fought and the fact is we
were just too busy we're just and John
remember when he had finally he still
came to work when he had swine flu we
had to put a tape around his desk so no
one to get too close then yeah stay home
with you had swine by the way it wasn't
worth it and you know one of the
challenges that we faced has been
learning how to scale the culture you
know when it was just 12 of us in a
small Palo Alto office we always had a
pulse on what was going on just by the
sheer number of hours that we spent
together and very confined spaces and I
was the only girl and 13 guys but you
know how do you think about scaling
transparency and collaboration and
creativity when you're now 85 people and
you have new engineers and new
executives and new advisors and you've
never worked with any of them before and
one of the things that we realized was
that we had an opportunity to completely
change what it meant to be an aerospace
company so traditional aerospace they're
very risk-averse the very Bureau
pratik and they're largely beholden to
meeting the the specs of the US
government and at skybox we like to say
we're bringing the Silicon Valley
approach to aerospace and we're building
satellites like Silicon Valley companies
build anjal software and we're always
losing the latest and greatest
technologies and just iterating really
fast and one of the ways we've tried to
reinforce that culture is just to hire
people that are just from very diverse
backgrounds give them an environment to
innovate that's kind of unencumbered of
traditional aerospace and so if you walk
through our office you'll walk through
an engineering bullpen you'll see
aerospace engineers that are working on
space qualified hardware and they're
sitting next to software engineers that
are building out data mining and
computer algorithms and you know from
the engineering bullpen to our class
10,000 clean room worse system engineers
are integrating components on our two
satellites you might trip a word dog or
get hit by a nerf gun and another thing
that we were really focused on was
learning how to scale our transparency
was really important to us and so every
Sunday night Dan sends out an email to
the entire team outlining the five
challenges five goals and
accomplishments for the past following
week on Mondays we have our all hands
where we celebrate anniversaries for all
our employees introduce new ones and
give updates across the departments and
after each board meeting we actually
break the entire board packs to the
entire team and so it was really
important that we are briefing the board
exactly where we're briefing the
employees so everybody knows what our
key milestones our challenges or risks
even our cash position and we're moving
so fast that we can't afford have
restricted information flows so we
always err on a full disclosure and and
finally if you look at the people at
skybox you know we've just afford been
really really fortunate just to have
just an amazing collection of people
from RF engineers to you I software
engineers and if you look at why they
actually joined skybox it wasn't because
of pay I mean some of our employees
outgrew to their kids from high schools
to relocate across the country they
dropped out of their PhDs and you know
we really were able to hire people on
the basis that we would provide them a
very unique once in a lifetime journey
to revolutionize the way that businesses
make decisions and people view the world
we were able to hire people based on the
fact that we could give engineers the
opportunity to build software and her
we're in infrastructure to build
something that actually goes into space
it moves at 7,000 miles per hour and
beams down two terabyte of data per day
and I think you know we're we're just
getting started and we still have a very
long way to go to prove ourselves but I
think that you know the 40 of us will
look back in about 10 years and we'll
really judge how well we've done based
on how we scale our culture and I think
we get that right everything else will
follow so with that I'll hand it back to
Dan all right wow that's a hard one to
follow up to you um you know I think in
conclusion you know one of the one of
the biggest lessons for us and really
what kind of all these lessons adds up
to is that you know it's a it's it is
not a specific point or milestone you
know this really is a journey if you
make the decision to leave the walls of
Stanford and go out and actually try and
create a company you have to be open to
the journey of growing from being an
entrepreneur to you know to an executive
to an operator just someone that is out
in the field and is doing it and that is
a hard transition and it doesn't take
days or weeks or months it takes years
and it takes really a dogged
determination to continue challenging
yourself and the people around you and
on one hand to as Ching you said not be
not let people tell you no for an answer
but at the same time you know knowing
when to be open to changing your own
assumptions the way you look at the
world the way you look at the people
around you and the way that you look at
yourself and so you know I'd like to
think that you know we are for good
examples of people that have made the
first few steps on that journey we still
have a long way to go absolutely but you
know skybox for us has been the journey
of a lifetime already and you know our
emails are just our first names at
skybox com you know if you are
interested in joining us or working on
data analysis or you know trying to get
outside of the walls of Stanford and you
know getting a little bit more of a
taste of what we're doing you know
please reach out to us you know we come
and do these things because we want to
meet more people we want to get our
names out there and like Julian put it
we're always looking for the next person
that's going to move the needle for Sky
box in the future and now so please
reach out to us and come find us with
that will open it up for questions you
want to kick your ask questions all
right fire away yes the black challenges
for within your satellites into space
this is the question that John always
answered in the series a pitch that came
up every single one of the hundred and
fifty pictures that we did and to
refresh my memory you said the legal
challenges oh yeah so it turns out space
is fairly heavily regulated funnily that
we need to get a license from the US
government in order to be able to sell
pictures commercially from space and now
the beauty of that license is space is
treated kind of like Antarctica it's
free for everybody we have restrictions
as to who we can sell to there are a few
countries and a few individuals bad
people that we can't sell to but if we
do have the ability to sell our imagery
to most places on earth and take
pictures of most places on earth and you
know it's funny they Stanford especially
the business school talks about being at
creating global businesses well skybox
just by its very nature it we're global
we're also global in terms of how we put
our satellites into space our first
satellite will launch on a converted
Russian nuclear missile out on the
border of Russia and Kazakhstan and how
they do this is they literally take the
warheads out and they put our satellite
in and a drill with 4 bolts they go and
off we go and so there are also tons of
challenges a lot of paperwork to get to
that an amazing a lot of paperwork to
get to that yeah and speaking of the
paperwork you know working with the US
government to make sure that our
regulators are comfortable with us
taking you know relatively advanced
technology over there for that it has
also been a big challenge for us so what
that means is I've spent a lot of time
in DC over the last four years yes in
the back and you mentioned me a real
time what barriers are there to getting
in real time or do you see that being a
real planet for the google earth or
google maps in the future on it i think
that's a that's a great question and
what what is the sort of future of
satellite imagery how real time can this
actually be you know part of that is a
little bit like Google sitting back in
1996 saying how big can the internet be
I mean the simple idea was we want to
index the internet you know and they
probably had no idea at the time just
how far that simple idea could take them
and I think you know in our case the the
timeliness of the imagery is a direct
function of the number of satellites you
have right so that's that's why we're
building lots of smaller satellites
because we want to get to that
timeliness and you know in reality we
could take that a very long way you know
for us the the tipping point really what
we see is a line in the sand is having
enough satellites up that we're able to
to offer relatively high confidence to
customers that we could get them daily
data now something they can use to make
a decision every day and that's that's
really the North Star that we're aiming
at right now but you know how much
farther could this go beyond that we'll
all just have to wait and see together
yes Beck how much is your the weight of
your payload and you see you're waiting
for payload increasing or decreasing and
what's the line Florida's line-item
causes at the launch cause well actually
it turns out that satellites and
satellite launches are expensive even
when you're trying to do a lower-cost
version of them you know one of the
things that's been important for us at
skybox is to reduce costs while not
sacrificing
tense and quality right and so we follow
very stringent sort of very industry
standard procedures when it comes to the
validation and the testing and the
deployment of our satellites and so you
know our current payload may increase a
little bit over time but you know the
size of that payload drives the quality
of the image that you see here and so
really we are focused on putting up more
satellites so that we can drive that
timeliness versus putting up bigger
satellites so that we can see better
pictures yes just wondering cuz stupid
shape that the engineers we do have to
do get to be heavy all those one wonder
if you get the company can ever created
an environment for the other other
companies I was going to actually
complete everything surprise or you know
to increase to introduce some of the
accessories or whatever a hard way or
you so that you don't really have
anything myself to repeat the question
so I think if I understand the question
correctly was can we create an
environment where we allow other
companies to sort of compete on building
pieces of our technology pieces of our
platform and and by effect reducing our
internal costs and the answer is
absolutely we already do you know take
take advantage of Best of Breed
commercially available technologies when
they're available and if we have to
build something ourselves we do at the
same time people have often asks us even
when we're raising money what are you
guys going to do when someone else can
build a satellite at a lower cost than
you can and my answer is consistently
been will buy it from them because
ultimately for us you know we view
skybox will be a success when we are the
access point for providing people the
information that they need based upon
the imagery and other data that we
collect and if there is a you know
lower-cost way to do it with someone
else's satellite whether it means
bringing in UAVs or balloons or cell
phone cameras and ultimately it's all
about providing somebody the answer to
the question that they have not
necessarily about skybox being the one
that moans the specific piece of
technology in that entire stack
yes I look like it's a competition from
Gary envision making your place right
yeah we did drill a hole in the bottom
for your pen that was funny um the
question was how do we view potential
competition from other collection
sensors from UAVs from airplanes and the
like and I think you know this is kind
of a follow-on to what Julian just said
I mean we really don't view ourselves as
having competitors I mean we it sounds
kind of cliche but I mean we see this as
a partner industry and we realize that
these applications of tomorrow will not
be created based on Sky box data alone
they'll require data from other
satellites they'll require data from
airplanes they'll require data from the
ground and in some cases getting data
from a UAV that you can pop up locally
can loiter in real time you know in
combining that with some of our
information is going to be the best way
to solve the problem if you're trying to
get you know new information on what's
happening you know in a very distant
part of the world you know it becomes
very hard to send a UAV there and you
know having that global satellite that's
constantly coming overhead everywhere on
Earth you know is going to be the way to
solve that so for us it's about the data
integration in the end and how do we
allow you know everyone's data to kind
of come together and be used in a way
that that solves these big questions in
a way we can't today yes how many
satellites gives you daily yeah
and so we're a little quiet still
publicly on what it costs you know and
and the the truth of the matter is that
it's slightly variable on how many
satellites you need to actually be able
to kind of guarantee that daily revisit
now roughly speaking six satellites of
our size are have the opportunity to see
anywhere on earth once a day but then
you think about places that are cloudy
you know these satellites come over at
the same time every day so they're in
what's called a sun-synchronous orbit so
San Francisco it can be a little hard to
collect at nine thirty in the morning
right so when you put more of these
satellites and instead of six you say
about 12 or 18 or 24 you're able to come
over at different times a day then you
have the ability to shoot around clouds
more and you also have the ability to
service multiple customers that all have
competing needs in the same region so
that's you know those that's the order
of scale that you know getting back to
that kind of current North Star we're
pointing towards some of the
applications for this I mean clearly
it's very black yeah it's if you want it
funny if you want have a funny
conversation with somebody like sit them
down in an office like John staying with
the hedge funds and say okay guess what
you can see anywhere on the earth at any
time you know what do you do with it
right and for most people that's a
pretty big it's pretty big leap from
that concept to what they do on their
daily basis sitting at you know their
computer terminal right and so the there
are kind of different classes of
applications that really excite us you
know and I think that number one
environmentally being able to understand
kind of broadly you know across the
planet what's happening with with crops
with water with with forestry with
things that you know impact you know
life for all of us here on earth but
also have a major impact on on supply
chains you know that require natural
resources and and on the prices of
things like commodities and I think
that's a very interesting rich data
source that is not well understood today
the other kind of general class of
problems for us is we call asset
monitoring just being able to say well
you know I'm I'm the manager here in the
United States that's responsible for
something that's being built in a
factory overseas you know I how do I
audit them how do I understand what's
actually happening somebody told me
there's a factory there is there are
their trucks outside of it they're
they're actually things happening there
that would indicate that they're making
the parts that I asked them to make I
can get on a plane and fly over there
maybe I can call somebody on the phone
or I can say you know show me what's
been going on the last week so those are
the types of things that you know the
specifics of you know which industry and
which type of information I mean you
know you can break those into a million
different pieces but those kind of
general ideas are the ones that really
excite us and also you know I just add a
little bit to dance comment you know one
of the things that we're really excited
about are the application for
humanitarian I mean imagine having real
time video over anywhere on earth right
after an earthquake so you'll be able to
deploy relief agencies optimally you
can't do that today with existing salads
because the timeliness is not there and
you know we'll definitely be looking out
for that next year sorry yes in the
front hi um I was wondering about the
different controlling interest in the
company do you guys have foundered still
have a controlling interest and if not
how to deal with a bureaucracy and the
different controlling interest wall you
still retain indentation I think part of
that question boils back down to that
kind of journey that I talked about you
know and being willing to kind of accept
events as they unfold because they're
going to be different for every company
right you know fundamentally it is tough
to go out and build a very capital
intensive business right you know it
requires a lot of everything a lot of
people a lot of money a lot of different
types of expertise and a lot of parties
at the table now it works trong
believers that you know in doing that
creates a much larger opportunity as
well and that's what gets us excited but
you know I always urge people to really
think about if you're gonna start a
company do you think about what you want
your life to be like the next five years
you know is it more important for you to
you know to have be with your social
circle kind of working in an environment
that you completely
control but might be a you know might be
a much smaller idea or are you really
excited by you know going after the big
swing the big idea even if there's going
to be other things that come along with
that you know that you're going to have
to grow up and get used to and you know
for us that going the opportunity that
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity you know
that people we've been fortunate enough
that people have given us to go out
there and really try and do something
big was well worth it they'll just throw
on an additional piece on that that I
like to tell people which is the sort of
numerical concept of controlling
interest is in a lot of ways a fallacy
because as soon as you bring on outside
outside investors it doesn't matter if
you're you know somehow able to do it
and only sold them two percent of the
company you know how about outside
investors and you no longer have a
complete controlling interest you have
to be working around the table and
figuring out ways to you know bring
everybody's opinions and decisions to go
how do you from the company before you
see you say you have to get a career
plan and make a bowl and a this picture
30 days to get a facial star
review was found up first part credit
cards got it guys the Learjet was after
the series the weirdo is after that none
of us have a credible I'm like do not
have that credit yeah Blackheart yeah no
I an addict record you guys know we
actually didn't spend that much I mean
to be quite honest you know for us we
you know we were buying tickets to DC
and back that was we're taking the
red-eye you know so we weren't staying
in hotels and then John big on couches
yeah John will grant us a 20 foot long
buick lesabre that costs eight dollars a
day to rent or something like that we
stay in the you know thirty dollar night
hotel that three to a room three to a
room yeah I wasn't in the same room
jorgensen
that's a good point it's important for
the historical record yes yes so his
face any sort of opposition from like
playing privacy advocates there's so so
we really haven't haven't to date um and
I think a big reason to that has to do
with what Dan was talking about earlier
and then at the resolution that we're at
there's really a certain level of
inherent anonymity you know we're not
looking at people's license plates
you're not going to get accidentally
caught walking out of the front the
front door of your house it's more about
understanding you know the slower
movements of larger objects that that
indicate you know macroeconomic or macro
security trends and I think the other
the other piece as well as gets to the
application side stuff that Chingy was
talking about in that you know the the
public's widest exposure to satellite
imagery i think other than google earth
which is really old and static but as
far as public's publishers a new
satellite imagery is when there's a
earthquake in Haiti or there's a you
know a nuclear reactor and tsunami in
Japan and suddenly we're using this data
to understand you know impact a human
life come up with with security plants
come up with response plans and it
becomes in some ways a lot easier to you
know ole a certain concerns and you say
look at the amazing things that will be
able to enable for Humanity with a
greater access to this data and I think
that's really a lot of that comes down
to resolution you know we we have
purposefully chosen to pursue a business
that really does not have the sort of
image resolution you know to be able to
to go down to that micro level and we
want to be about the macro level and in
a world where another street view in a
world where there's the Twitter
real-time feed in a world where there's
Facebook and we feel that we're actually
you know we're not going down to that
sort of same level that that gets to
some of those privacy concerns make it a
good one Qing you yeah right
we feed off those any right now the old
life again seeing you at the Bellinger's
it's been glorious I really ha ha ha I
mean I was just so lucky that these guys
actually let me be part of the team and
you know the four of us really you know
work really well together we're
extremely different people with
different personalities different
temperaments and you know we all do very
different things but are just able to
get a lot of things done and we were
fortunate because we had that dating
period in the class where you figure out
really quickly do you want to travel
around the world with these guys and
spend a long hours with them do they
raise your thinking do they elevate your
you know thought and for me was
absolutely yes I just ER you will agree
that this was absolutely fascinating
join me in thanking this wonderful team
you